now today's a big day for you well maybe
we'll say today is the day theoretically
that all these whatever it is thirty
thousand JFK related documents are
supposed to be released you know the law
was passed twenty-five years ago today
yes by Bush right that I signed by Bush
I think reluctantly see the JFK movie
right by Oliver Stone caused a great
public interest to return to the
assassination it was on the was as a
reaction to that that the Congress
passed the 1992 JFK Records release act
and the first tranche of documents that
they thank you very much that they
released was very interesting we found
out a lot of things we didn't know what
was stuff in that first in that for
example we have a memo from J Edgar
Hoover the head of the FBI to President
Lyndon Johnson that says mr. president
we have learned that the KGB has
conducted their own independent
investigation into John Kennedy's murder
and they have concluded mr. president
that you were the ringleader we have a
letter from French intelligence to
Jacqueline Kennedy was a response
obviously to a request from her they say
that they have done their own
investigation they published it as a
book called farewell to arms and they
concluded that Lyndon Johnson was the
ringleader mhm
there's a memo from J Edgar Hoover to
the head of the FBI in Dallas
instructing him to brief George Bush of
the CIA about the activities of
anti-castro Cubans in the Dallas area
the problem with that was George Bush
said under oath he wasn't working for
the CIA in 1963 so a bunch of little
interesting things right just and and it
all it really does is raise more
questions right because it's not proof
cuz you could sit there and say like
well the KGB had a reason to say that
that lyndon b johnson was the ringleader
because they would want america to lose
faith in in their elected leaders right
in a sense i mean that we didn't know
this at the time but Nikita Khrushchev
took John and Bobby Kennedy to the
cleaners in the in the Cuban Missile
Crisis the story you've been told that
they that they faced down the Russians
and that's right so question I saw the
movie total BS what we removed our
missiles from Turkey and Italy in a
secret deal that was classified for 40
years so the military knew it at the
time but the American people didn't know
it
Khrushchev had just taken Kennedy to the
cleaners on on the on the missile crisis
and you know he considered him a young
kal-el guy that he could bully there was
no reason for the Russians at that point
to get rid of John Kennedy mmm-hmm now
what do you but there would be a reason
for the Russians to simply come out I'm
not saying that the Russians were
responsible there there would be a
reason for the Russians to just come out
with a report that made it so that
people question American leadership
right wasn't a public report this was up
oh I see this was an intelligence
document there's a there is a there's an
effort to pin this on the Russians and
the Cubans Johnson says it several times
but I think he has a motive in that we
also know that Fidel Castro had reached
out to Kennedy through a back-channel
French journalist and said maybe we
should sit down maybe we should see if
we could normalize relations that was in
the works at the time Kennedy was killed
again unlikely that Castro therefore is
involved in the killing Castro was
reportedly surprised but the diplomat
who passed the message there were -
there was a French journalist in an
American diplomat
both said Castro was amenable to a
sit-down with JFK and the Americans at
the time that weren't JFK did not want
peace with Cuba there the the
military-industrial complex the deep
state the American war machine
they were awed they wanted an invasion
of Cuba I think and they may have wanted
World War 3 with the Russians they were
very belligerent good god we've got to
get rid of Jack Kennedy he's for peace
as we talk here at about 9:30 5:00
Eastern Time on the day that these
documents are supposed to be released
what are the odds that we're gonna see
them are they pretty good well I think
we're going to see documents the odds
however are
were whelming that the National Archive
will do what they did in July when they
put out a small batch of documents I
think is a test so much of it was
redacted and censored held back that
it's meaningless so you don't think any
questions will be answered well it's I
put it this way I think the Central
Intelligence Agency bureaucrats have got
to figure out a medium course here
because the president wants disclosure
if they hand him thirty one hundred
pages which are incomprehensible he's
smart enough to say this isn't this is
you know your countermanding my orders
this is in essence nullifying what I
decided right show me what's what's
covered here I want to see if it's
really in the interest of national
security
everybody involved has been dead for 50
years so that's what Trump that's trumps
part in this because some people are
saying that Trump is getting too much
credit for this because you know it's
it's the law it was going to be exposed
regardless of who the president is
here's how the law reads yes the release
was scheduled for October 26th unless
the president decides to delay it he
alone has the authority to knock it back
for another 25 years which he could have
done